Now that I'm doing chemo, should I still take my friend Bendizal and CBD?
I would say yes, so you know, it's they're not exclusive of one another. Just like
okay, so let's say you start out an alternative path and you're using the right
and doing herbs while I'm doing chemo now. Should I stop taking the mushrooms? Should I stop doing
the right? Well, absolutely not. You know, that it, you know, anything that you're going to do that
is going to help you, you know, is going to be better if you're, you know, if you're doing chemo,
doing all these other things are going to be helpful. So no, Bendizal is not, you know, an issue with
chemo. It's not an, you know, an antioxidant where you shouldn't take an antioxidant. I don't have
anybody with antioxidants really. So it's, there's nothing typically that you're taking
if you, if you started chemo that you really should stop taking.